welcome to Hannity Park we have a
raucous crowd thank you all for coming
we have a live studio audience a very
busy news night tonight now Trump on the
ground in East Palestine Ohio something
by the way neither Biden nor pothole
mayor Pete could ever find the time to
do also Joe Biden is falling up the
stairs yet again to Air Force One if the
only good news he only fell once he
didn't fall three times like the last
time anyway we've got that video coming
up also here is pothole Pete taking some
personal time in Washington D.C after a
pretty bizarre encounter with the
journalists we got that video for you
but our top story tonight involves a
special grand jury in the great state of
Georgia they are now tasked with probing
election and afference accusations
against former president Trump and his
allies now here's the problem the grand
jury's four woman a woman by the name of
Emily Coors has now embarked on what is
a truly bizarre potentially on that
ethical Countrywide press tour and to
date no one has been indicted in Georgia
and the investigation is supposed to be
ongoing that is not stopping Emily Coors
from gushing about her experience in the
grand jury let's see she's talked to the
New York Times the AP fake news CNN
msdnc NBC news and it appears that the
jury for woman is Overjoyed with the
prospect of potentially putting former
president Trump behind bars but will be
disappointed if no charges are filed now
she was dying as the poor person it
would have been her job to swear in the
president do you swear to tell the truth
the whole truth nothing but the truth
will help you God
uh she didn't get that opportunity now
watch though as she's smirking and
smiling and laughing her way through
several what a bizarre and insane
interviews take a look
did the grand jury recommend an
indictment of former president Trump
I'm not going to speak on exact
indictments
so nothing that would surprise people
who have been following this
probably not
um I wouldn't want to characterize
anyone else's reaction of course but
so that was when we heard a lot in
testimony but probably not did you
personally want to hear from the former
I wanted to hear from the former
president but honestly I kind of wanted
to subpoena the former president because
I got to swear everybody in and so I
thought it'd be really cool to get 60
seconds with President Trump of me
looking at him and being like do you
solemnly swear and me getting to swear
him in I just I kind of just thought
that would be an awesome moment there
are indictments recommended of course is
it more than 12 people is it more than
20 people
I think if you look at the page numbers
of the report there's about
six pages in the middle that got cut out
allow for spacing
it's not a short list
not a short list after everything that
you've seen what would your reaction be
if the da decides against bringing any
charges after what you've seen
I will be sad if nothing happens
like that's that's about my only request
there is is for something to happen
does she seem impartial to anybody in
this audience
oh okay does she even appear competent
does she see does she understand the
gravity of the situation okay laughing
at the prospect of literally ruining
people's lives putting them behind bars
taking away the Liberty their freedom uh
this is not acceptable it's not
appropriate it's not how Justice in
America is supposed to work that what we
saw is a travesty in fact it might even
be against the law we'll check in with
our experts in a few minutes now
according to the grand jury handbook
there is one in the state of Georgia
Georgia's quote shall keep the
deliberations of the grand jury secret
and less called upon to give evidence uh
thereof in some court of law in this
state oh CNN or the New York Times or Ms
DNC is out of courtroom I don't think so
the same handbook also makes the
following recommendations quote do not
discuss cases with your fellow jurors or
anyone else outside of the Jury Room and
according to a ruling from the U.S
Supreme Court quote the proper
functioning of our grand jury system
depends upon secrecy of grand jury
proceedings she was telling us
everything she thought about pretty much
everybody any Fair judge will throw out
any conclusions of this special grand
jury now still it is unclear if the jury
for a woman broke any laws during her
press tour but tonight even the media
mob they are deeply concerned about her
actions and her behavior and they should
be take a look good Lord the mere fact
that you have the right to do something
and she has a right to speak as a
citizen and even the grand jury rules in
Georgia you know as long as she's not
speaking about deliberations she's
allowed to the mere fact you have the
right doesn't mean that you ought to do
it she's undermined the integrity and
Independence of the grand jury this is
just you know at least in my experience
covering courts not helpful to a
district attorney when they are trying
to put their kids together this is a
horrible idea and I guarantee you that
prosecutors are wincing watching her go
on this I was wincing just watching her
eagerness to like you know hint at stuff
but I think that she could destroy this
kid I will say I was thoroughly enjoying
the interviews you know like everyone
else I was giggling and cracking up and
stuff but then when I put my federal
prosecutor hat on I was like oh no she's
compromising the Integrity of the
investigation hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else